So you act things out,
right?
Do you act things out?
And that's a kind of competence.
And then you imagine what you act out and you imagine what everyone else acts
out.
And so there's a tremendous amount of inflammation in your action.
And then that information is translated up into the dream and into art,
into mythology and literature.
And there's a tremendous amount of information in that.
And then some of that is translated into articulated thought.
And I'll give you a quick example of something like that.
I think this is partly what happens in exodus when Moses comes up with the law,
you know,
he's wandering around with the Israelites forever and the desert and they're,
they're like going left and going right and worshiping idols and like having a
hell of a time and um,
you know,
get in rebellious and Moses goes up on the mountain and he has this tremendous
revelation sort of in the sight of God and illuminates him.
And he comes down with the law.
You think,
well,
you know,
Moses acted as a judge.
I know this is a mythological story.
Moses acted as a judge in the desert.
He was continually mediating between people who are having problems constantly
trying to keep peace.
And so what are you doing when you're turning to keep pieces?
You're trying to understand what peace is,
right?
You have to apply the principles.
Well,
what are the principles?
you don't know the principals or whatever satisfies people enough to make peace
and maybe you do that 10,000 times and then you get some sense of,
Oh,
here's the principles that bring peace.
And then one day it blasts into your consciousness like,
like a revelation.
Here's the rules that were already acting out.
Well that's the 10 commandments.
It's,
they're there to begin with and Moses comes forward and says,
look,
this is already basically what we're doing,
but now it's codafide.
Right?
And like that's all historical process that's condensed into a single story.
But obviously that happened because we have written law,
right?
And that emerged in,
in good legal systems that emerges from the bottom up.
That's English.
Common law is exactly like that,
right?
It's single decisions that are predicated on principles that are then then
articulated and made into the body of law.
The body of law is something you act out.
That's why it's a body of law.
If you're a good citizen,
you act out the body of law and the body of law has principles.
Okay,
so the question is,
there's principles that guide our behavior.
What are those principles?
Well,
I think when you,
if you're,
if you want the initial answer of what the Ark Archaic is,
real lights meant by God,
that's something like what they meant.
You know,
it's not a good enough explanation.
But imagine that you,
that you have,
that you're a chimpanzee and you have a powerful,
uh,
dominant figure at the pinnacle of your society,
that that represents power.
Now,
more than that because it's not sheer physical prowess that keeps a chimp at the
top of the hierarchy.
It's much more complicated than that.
But you could say,
well,
there's,
there's a principle that the dominant person manifests.
And then you might say,
well,
that principle shines forth even more brightly.
If you know 10 people who are dominant,
powerful,
and you can extract out what dominance means from that,
you can extract out what power means from that.
And then you can divorce the concept from the people.
And we had to do that at some point because we can say power in a human context
and we can imagine what that means.
But it's divorced from any specific manifestation of power.
Well,
how the hell did we do that?
Like that's so complicated when if you're a chimp,
the power is in another chimp.
It's not some damn abstraction.
Well,
so the,
so the question is think,
think about it.
We're in these hierarchies,
many of them across centuries.
We're trying to figure out what the guiding principle is.
We're trying to extract out the core of the guiding principle and we turned that
into a representation of a pattern of Ba.
Well,
it's something like that.
That's God.
It's an abstracted,
the ideal and it's,
it's,
it's put in personified form.
It manifests itself in persona find form.
But that's okay because what we're trying to get at is the,
in some sense,
the essence of what it means to be a properly functioning and properly,
properly functioning properly social and property competent individual.
We're trying to figure out what that means.
You needed an embodiment,
you needed ideal that's abstract and then you could act out that would enable
you to understand what that means.
And that's what we've been driving out.
So that's the first hypothesis.
In some sense,
I'm going to go over some of the,
some of the attributes of this abstract,
that ideal that we've formalized as God.
But that's the first sort of hypothesis is that a philosophical or moral ideal
manifests itself first as a concrete pattern of behavior that's characteristic
of a single individual.
And then it's a set of individuals and then it's an abstraction from that set.
And then you have the abstraction.
It's so important.
So here's a political implication.
For example,
one of the debates we might say between early Christianity and the late Roman
empire was whether or not an emperor could be God literally right to be deified,
to put enough to be put in a temple.
And you can see why that might happen because that's someone at the pinnacle of
a very steep hierarchy has a tremendous amount of power and influence.
But the Christian response to that was never confuse the specific sovereign with
the principle of sovereignty itself.
It's brilliant to see,
see how difficult it is to come up with an idea like that so that even the
person who has the power is actually subordinate to something else subordinate
to Ah,
let's call it a divine,
for lack of a better word,
so that even the king himself is subordinate to the principal.
And we still believe that because we believe that our president or prime
minister is subordinate to the damn law,
whatever the body of law,
right?
There's a principle inside that that even the leader is subordinate to.
And without that,
you could argue you can't even have a civilized society because your,
your leader immediately turns into something that's transcendent and all
powerful.
And I mean,
that's certainly what happened in the Soviet Union and what happened in Mao's
China and what happened in Nazi Germany because there was nothing for the
powerful to subordinate themselves to,
you're supposed to be subordinate to God.
So what does that mean?
While we're going to tear that idea apart,
but partly what it means is that you're subordinate,
even if you're sovereign to the principle of sovereignty itself.
And then the question is,
what the hell is the principle of sovereignty?
And I could say we have been working that out for a very long period of time.